[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a este especial
informativo en fra 224 yo soy andrés
meza muñoz facebook ahora llamado meta
captó las miradas del mundo durante este
2021 como nunca antes esto por cuenta de
varias crisis el masivo apagón que dejó
a millones de personas sin servicio las
explosivas declaraciones de una ex
empleada que acusó a la compañía de
ignorar la forma en que sus productos
afectan a los menores y hasta su cambio
de nombre en esta emisión especial
analizaremos estos temas pero antes
echemos un vistazo a los hechos de este
año que pusieron a facebook contra las
cuerdas
4 de octubre de 2021 miles de personas
recurren en masa a otras redes sociales
para reportar que no pueden acceder a
facebook instagram o whatsapp en
cuestión de horas las denuncias se
cuentan por millones es un hecho
facebook ha colapsado no reciben ningún
mensaje porque las plataformas no
funcionan
profesionalmente definitivamente es un
revés y personalmente siempre estoy en
la aplicación así que apesta esto es lo
peor no es un fallo en los servidores
dejo desconectados a unos tres mil
millones de usuarios durante horas un
fuerte golpe para la empresa y además
costoso sus acciones cayeron en un 5 por
ciento pero lo peor estaba por venir
mainz frentes auc en mi nombre es
francés jóvenes solía trabajar en
facebook me uní a esta compañía porque
pienso que tiene el potencial de sacar
lo mejor de nosotros pero estoy aquí hoy
porque creo que sus productos dañan a
los niños aviva en la división y
debilitan nuestra democracia en ubicar
maxi francés joven trabajaba como
gerente de producto en facebook y sólo
días atrás se había presentado en
televisión como la responsable de haber
filtra los documentos internos de la
empresa según los cuales facebook
reconocía cuán dañino serán sus
productos para niños y adolescentes
ahora hablaba frente al congreso
estadounidense sobre cómo la empresa
ignoró estos hechos y antepone a sus
ganancias económicas frente al bienestar
de los usuarios facebook criticó la
forma según la cual se tergiversa va su
trabajo y en medio de la que es tal vez
su peor crisis decidió cambiar su nombre
meta se hace llamar ahora en referencia
a su nuevo enfoque construir un meta
verso un espacio virtual compartido
donde las personas pueden interactuar
pero la medida levanta las alertas sobre
una compañía que ha estado envuelta en
escándalos por masivas filtraciones de
datos personales de sus usuarios además
de mensajes de odio y noticias falsas
que se cuelan en sus plataformas
expertos y usuarios creen que sea su
fundador mark zuckerberg que cuesta
moderar el contenido que se mueve en
espacios como instagram o whatsapp es
extraño pensar que pueda controlar todo
un universo virtual ahora el
interrogante es si podrá esta tormenta
asentar un presidente o si bien la
empresa se recuperará y seguir adelante
como lo ha hecho en el pasado
y para analizar este tema saludamos en
la ciudad de bogotá a samir stefan
analista digital y cofundador de tetera
punto cero samir bien bienvenido a
france 24 le trasladó la pregunta con la
que terminamos este informe podría esta
tormenta que atraviesa meta a sentar un
precedente o la empresa se recuperará y
seguirá adelante como lo ha hecho en el
pasado
hola andrés cómo estás pues la pregunta
que haces es muy interesante sobre todo
si uno mira lo que ha pasado en los años
anteriores y es que creo que hemos visto
en tal vez en la última década tres o
cuatro ocasiones en las que muchos de
nosotros hemos dicho es este el fin de
facebook es este la estocada final a un
negocio que ha vivido el mayor escándalo
y para bien o para mal de todos los años
lo que hemos visto es que al final no
pasó nada al final las ventas siguen
creciendo los números de usuarios se
mantienen en el precio de la acción
sigue aumentando entonces yo lo que creo
es que este año hay una diferencia
sustancial con lo que hemos visto todos
los años pasados es que por fin vemos
autoridades de diferentes países por ir
así y vamos a tomar medidas pero la
verdad tendremos que esperar a hoy y si
tú miras la acción a pesar de todo lo
que ha pasado la acción sigue estando
16% por encima de cuando empezó entonces
pues por ahora pareciera que el impacto
es más mediático pero menos financiero
ahora samir estos escándalos se han
repetido desde que facebook empezó a
crecer al final la víctima siempre es el
usuario pero a pesar de esto seguimos
usando las mismas redes sociales no hay
represalias por parte de nosotros a qué
cree que se debe esto porque seguimos
usando estos mismos productos
yo creo que al final del día la compañía
hizo algo muy bien hecho al comienzo no
y fue a ofrecer un servicio que la gente
le dio valor la posibilidad de estar
conectado la posibilidad de encontrarse
con con amigos y conocidos de atrás pero
también estar conectado con el día a día
y rápidamente hizo dos cosas que son
claves la primera es la manera en que
creció y son tres la segunda la manera
en que compró esa competencia muy rápido
que vio que podía hacerle daño como el
caso de instagram y la tercera como
monto a los modelos de mercadeo
empresarial dentro del mundo de redes
sociales hoy en día es un gran
porcentaje de la población que no solo
los usa para conectarse con amigos y
conocidos sino que por ahí por donde se
entera de los productos y servicios que
terminan comprando es por ahí que
interactúa con las marcas entonces el
pau tante no se quiere salir porque el
usuario no se quiere salir pero el
usuario no se puede salir porque es ahí
donde ocurre todo y no hay muchas otras
alternativas pero por un lado se volvió
más como de opinión como de debate como
de política snap sigue siendo digamos de
compañía de más de los jóvenes pero al
final del día entre facebook que ahora
está muy enfocado los viejos e instagram
que está muy enfocado en los jóvenes
sumado a un modelo de mensajería como el
de whatsapp hoy en día son imbatibles en
eeuu
hay un término que es el como fire of
music out y la verdad es que la mayoría
la gente no se sale de facebook o no se
sale y de esta gran por como por crisis
me salí de que me perdí samir y a través
de los productos de metas podemos hacer
ya muchas cosas compras hace reservas
solicitar citas médicas etcétera no es
esto demasiado poder para una red social
o estamos armando una tormenta en un
vaso de agua
no yo creo que sí yo creo que es
demasiado poder para una sola compañía y
es que al final del día andrés si tú
miras la compañía sabe más de ti que lo
que tú mismo sabes si les hemos enseñado
a los algoritmos tanto de nosotros que
ya no solo pueden predecir aquellas
cosas que nos van a interesar sino que
nos pueden manipular para que tomemos
acciones que a los pactantes y a la
compañía le hacen sentido y creo que ese
es el gran resultado de lo que estamos
viendo en los facebook papers es
precisamente eso es el nivel de
manipulación que puede llegar a tener
una compañía y si tú lo miras el debate
hoy grande es ese el debate es es
facebook demasiado grande es google
demasiado grande es amazon demasiado
grande pero en el caso de facebook pues
sobre el tamaño si no lo entre comillas
nocivo que puede llegar a ser el uso
indiscriminado de sus servicios como tú
lo dices hoy en día todo se hace por ahí
los usuarios cada vez están más
conectados más móviles
y son más sociales y ahí buenas buena
parte del mundo varios países en donde
la gente no es capaz de diferenciar
entre el internet y facebook
y facebook lo es todo en facebook es el
internet de la gente en muchos países en
asia y en áfrica es una realidad
completa saber dónde empezamos a poner
límites como nos damos cuenta de que
estamos dejando que estos productos
invadan nuestras vidas yo creo que se se
pregunta más difícil del mundo y te
remontó a enero cuando la compañía dijo
oigan voy a cambiar las políticas de
whatsapp sí y ahora voy a hacer esto
esto es lo mismo me voy me voy números
no esto no lo voy a permitir me voy
nadie se fue la gente abrió una cuenta
en telegram o una cuenta en signal los
que tienen iphone usamos un poquito más
de hay veces pero nadie cerró su cuenta
de whatsapp nadie cerró su cuenta de
facebook y si tú miras el número de
usuarios si se ha frenado la adopción
pero en realidad sigue creciendo y con
los nuevos servicios que se supone que
vamos a empezar a ver de parte de todo
lo que tiene que ver con con meta con
rai sense con él verso realidad
aumentada realidad virtual lo único que
va a pasar es que vamos a ahondar en ese
proceso entonces cada usuario tiene que
tomar una decisión y poner una raya que
creo yo que es sencilla de decir pero es
muy difícil de establecer y es ese
servicio que me está ofreciendo cuánto
vale por qué porque está el final estoy
pagando con que estoy pagando con mi
atención con información
estoy pagando yo soy el producto sí pero
este servicio que yo uso no es gratis yo
le estoy entregando a facebook y algo a
cambio qué tan interesante qué tan bueno
qué tan útil útil es el servicio que
está prestando para yo entregarle lo que
estoy entrega
samir hablemos ahora del cambio de
nombre de la compañía han surgido muchas
críticas y se dice que si facebook no ha
sido capaz de regular el discurso de
odio mucho menos será capaz de controlar
todo un universo como es el metaverso
que está construyendo
coincido con coincidió con el tema y es
el el metal es un va a pasar si cuando
tú miras para dónde están yendo todas
las compañías de tecnología todas las
compañías de tecnología entienden que
durante los últimos 10 años hemos venido
poniendo hemos venido creando una capa
digital que en algunos casos ya somos
capaces de sobreponer a nuestro físico
en otros todavía nos toca mirar los de
manera separada pero el siguiente gran
paso en tecnología va a ser la unión de
esos dos mundos bien sea porque desde tu
teléfono tu tableta tú ya puedes empezar
a ver ese mundo físico ese mundo digital
sobre el mundo físico un ejemplo fácil
de entender aunque es un juego era
pokemon go si tú en un sitio físico
podías encontrar un pokémon específico
un un un tema digital
y el tema es claramente lo que se viene
es esa conjunción de los dos mundos
seguramente apoyados en unos lentes que
te van a dar todo el día
pero la gran preocupación es ella me
usted no es capaz de parar
mensajes políticos que no hacen ningún
sentido o mensajes conspirativos como el
de ti banon y usted lo que me está
diciendo es que usted quiere ser el
líder de este nuevo universo pseudo
digital que voy a tener peligrosísimo
peligrosísimo porque además por un lado
está demostrado que no ha sido capaz
pero por otro lado si yo les sigo
entregando sea si yo le entrego lo poco
que me queda de de mi persona y me
sumerjo en un mundo absolutamente
digital controlado por usted cual cuál
puede ser el resultado si solo estando
conectado a través del teléfono hemos
visto las familias que se han destruido
hemos visto los niveles de adicción que
hemos visto hemos visto la gente que ha
terminado haciendo locuras como como las
protestas del 6 de enero en eeuu
engañados completamente con información
que todo el mundo sabía que era fácil
ahora a samir de quien depende ponerle
freno a esta compañía yo escribí cuando
él cuando el
escándalo de cambridge analítica
escribió en un artículo en 'the etcétera
que se titulaba el único responsable de
esto es usted usted y yo como usuarios
somos los únicos responsables porque al
final del día volvemos al cuento
cualquiera cualquier regulador en
cualquier país puede poner algunas
normas pero al final del día el único
que puede decidir qué tanta gasolina le
quiere seguir dando a la compañía con su
uso con compartir con montar información
con comprar a través de la plataforma
etcétera etcétera es usted usted es el
único que puede decir sabe que no le voy
a seguir compartiendo los datos de lo
que yo hago por fuera de la aplicación a
facebook no lo voy a seguir hasta que
facebook solo sepa lo que yo hago
adentro de la aplicación el único que
puede decir oiga voy a no voy a seguir
pasando
ocho horas diarias en instagram soy yo
entonces más allá de todo lo que
seguramente veremos en el 2022 de red
creo que la responsabilidad nuestra de
los usuarios y de tratar de tener una
relación sana con la red social
samir stefan analista digital y
cofundador de tetera punto sea muchas
gracias y ustedes también muchas gracias
por acompañarnos en este especial
informativo continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]